Think fast. -I'll show you this later. For
right now, we're going to unpack how to be
a quick thinker in conversation. My name is
Chad Littlefield. I love thinking about how
we create conversations that really matter. And
you might be watching this video because you want
to be a faster thinker in conversation and not
feel like you're just caught with these awkward
pregnant pauses. And in this video, I'm going to
share some pretty mind-blowing science of how fast
our brains can actually move in conversation
and 2 strategies that you can immediately use
the minute this video is over to be a quicker
thinker in conversation. And here's the promise.
If you get to the end of this video and you
feel like what I've shared doesn't actually
help you be a quicker thinker in conversation, you
can write me an angry email and I will actually
send you a deck of cards that will make you
a quicker thinker. This offer applies to like
the first 100 angry emails that I receive
and nothing beyond that. Let's get into it.
Alright. Have you ever heard of the 125 over 400
rule? The human brain can listen to up to about
400 words per minute. But the human mouth can
only speak on average at about 125 to 175 words
per minute. Even like professional auctioneers who
are talking really, really, really, really fast
only speak at like 350 words a minute. Meaning
that even an action it's why we can understand an
auctioneer, sometimes. It's why we can understand
auctioneer because our brains can listen
much faster than our mouths can speak. And in
this fact lies a really important idea which is
you can train yourself in conversation
to be a really quick thinker.
And one of the easiest ways to be a
quick thinker to have quick responses
because that's the point. Because you
don't want to just be a quick thinker
and just be thinking in conversation, right?
You want to be a quick thinker and you want
to respond with something useful, meaningful in
that moment. And so, in this video, we're going
to unpack 2 strategies that will help you think
much more quickly. The first is hidden behind
this lovely piece of white paper. And it comes
from improv, improvisation. Jazz in particular,
jazz musicians when they would jam together no
written music but they'd come and this beautiful
piece of music would flow out of this improvised
piece of jazz. It's really cool. Unscripted which
is how most conversations are, right? Unscripted
and so how do they do that? How do they think so
quickly? How do they adapt so quickly to each
other? An improv teacher would say they did it
with these 2 lovely words. "Yes, and..." And the
idea and the mindset here in improvisation is that
you're building, right? You're always building on
what somebody else is saying. So, imagine if you
were listening at 400 words a minute and you were
saying in your mind your response... You didn't
have to think about how to respond because you
knew your first 2 words were going to be "Yes,
and..." And you built on top of what they were
saying. As opposed to... You know, in improv as
opposed to "No, but..." Or "No, because...",
right? Which will shut down a conversation.
Now, let me be clear. You might not actually
respond with by saying these 2 words verbally.
You might not literally say... Well, Stephen.
Tell me something about your family. -I
have a brother who's adopted. -Yes, and that's
really cool, right?" Or "Yes and... My business
partner Will is actually also adopted." Right?
So, you might not actually respond with "Yes,
and..." because painfully awkward. Now, let's try
that again. Stephen, tell me something about your
family. -My brother is still adopted. -Whoa,
super cool. You're saying that it's making me
think immediately of my business partner Will
who was also adopted. The first chapter of our
book is actually about this really phenomenal
story and connection related to that, right? So,
the UCL one feels a little bit more natural. So,
you might not use these words. But the idea is
that I was building on something that Stephen
was saying in that moment. So, you got strategy
number one --"Yes, and..." build on what they
were saying. I would say even cooler than that,
I'm going to adapt the strategy. I'm going to add
to the library of beautiful insight that exists
in the world on how to do "Yes, and..." I'm
actually going to say let's get rid of yes and
and turn yes and into Yes, ask. Question mark?
Yes. Ask. Because in conversation, when you think
about how to be a quick thinker in conversation,
most likely if I were to guess and I don't know
your situation in your context. But most likely,
you want to be a quick thinker. You're thinking
about being a quick thinker because you want to
know what to say in response to what somebody else
has shared. And that is actually a lot harder I
would say than listening at 400 words a minute
and just thinking about what are you going to
ask afterward. You know, kids between the ages of
3 and 5 ask between 300 and 400 questions per day.
Adults ask between 6 to 12 questions per day.
So, somewhere along the line, our curiosity went
way down. And I would say this tool of "yes, ask"
Makes you not only a quick thinker but a really
phenomenal conversationalist. I'm not saying that
we should go back to 300 to 400 questions a day.
But if we were to even double our count, you would
appear to be a quicker thinker in conversation but
maybe more importantly that person would feel
seen, heard, and understood in the way that you
were responding that conversation. And I would
argue that that is more important than just being
a quick thinker because it's way more important to
be interested rather than interesting. And you got
to remember with this "yes, ask" curiosity is a
choice even if you don't identify as somebody who
is naturally genuinely curious. It's a switch.
You can turn it on at any given time. And you
can turn it off at any given time. If you like
this, I've created 2 card decks called We! Engage
Cards and We! Connect Cards. And they're really
phenomenal. There's 2 exercises in particular.
There's an exercise called story swap with We!
Engage Cards and there's an exercise called
conversation roulette. Really cool deck of cards
for a in a work context or an education context
to promote quicker thinking. Great way to warm up
a brainstorming session. Really remarkable way to
create conversations that matter and get some
comfortable conversation flowing. So, if you
want to free digital versions of either of these
during the links below. If you want these things
mailed to you there's also links for that as well.
I'm Chad and I hope that you have an awesome day.